hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
of each of the five ways discussed by
Thomas Aquinas in some Taylor logiai
first part question two article three
the fifth way is actually at least
textually the shortest and in some
respects the most attractive to certain
kinds of people but also viewed by other
people as perhaps the weakest of the
arguments that he's giving and it's a
bit different than the first three which
are what we typically call cosmological
arguments the fourth you know is an
argument based on degrees of being and
it might be its own special kind of
argument but it is also causal in a
sense the fifth is what we often label
from const time onward a teleological or
design argument it is beginning where
the others do with observation of the
world that we live in and experience and
in which we see things happening
and it's looking for how things turn out
and why they reach certain ends or if we
want to put it in a slightly different
not until Mystic language why they have
regular patterns of behavior it's not
completely
non-tomistic because he does use the
word
operator
acting you know behaving is another way
of translating it and what Thomas is
focused on here is not just regularity
but achieving certain ends or goals or
goods and doing so consistently
so he tells us
that this fifth way is based on
governance or rulership or guidedness or
whatever we want to call it arrangement
of things now sometimes it's translated
a little bit misleadingly for example
here in the black Friars based on the
guidedness of nature it is natural
things that he's going to be talking
about but this you know could extend to
things that aren't completely determined
by their nature like human beings as
we're going to see in his response to
the second objection which I think is is
closely connected with this the term
that Thomas is using is gubernation
you know governance is a cognit with
that and Ray ROM just means things
things in general now he doesn't say all
things so you know it could leave some
things out but
in the the argument he will bring up
omnis right so perhaps we should see
that there and how does he begin he says
well what we see vidimus
in
whatever it is aliqua that lacks
cognition so
let's pause on that for a minute
cognition that's a very abstract term
things that lack thinking things that
don't really think like we humans do
about what it is that they're trying to
do they act either naturally because of
you know the way that things are you
know if you think about you know throw a
rock up and it falls down we say oh law
of gravity
um well you know that is operating
according to certain physical
processes right and we could say the
same thing about chemistry and we can
get into biology we can talk about
plants or we can talk about you know
fungi or single-celled organisms and we
could say that they have a certain kind
of directedness right but it's not like
they're thinking to themselves
um sun is shining I think today I'd
better turn towards it just like I do
every other day or anything they just do
it right
um
bacteria don't think to themselves maybe
today I'll do things a little bit
different they're they're not thinking
they don't have cognition and you know
animals where do they fit in well it's
easy to say with certain lower animals
higher animals I don't know maybe
there's a discussion to be had there but
Thomas isn't so worried about that we
human beings according to him are
different as we see in the discussion of
the um response of the second objection
you know we have intelligence or
intellect and will a will that is
different than just a merely animal will
a voluntas because it's actually capable
of free and deliberate action
so things that are lacking cognition
what are examples of this natural bodies
you know again rocks plants animals all
those sorts of things and he says that
um
an orderedness of actions to an end
operantor
they act operantor according to propter
Phenom in accordance with some sort of
thing
um they have a goal they may not
actually cognize that goal maybe they
just feel that goal or they just act in
accordance with it and this leads to two
things that are closely connected for
Thomas so he says they always so semper
in Latin or often francuentius
act in the same way and the Latin there
is uh eodim Modo operantor right so they
act in the same manner or the same mode
is a way or behave is another way of
translating it so acting according to an
end leads to consistent action but
another aspect of this that he talks
about it is that they
things turn out for or follow quite
literally or it turns it you know things
work in such a way that the best in
quotas Optimum that which is the best
happens to be the case and you know the
best kind of relative right so
um let's take a bird of prey who goes in
and eats you know we'll take the famous
thing of the hawk and The Sparrow the
hawk swoops down and grabs the sparrow
or Dove or whatever other defenseless
bird you want and it's got it in its
claws and the little bird is like oh
please don't kill me don't eat me I
don't like this right it's definitely
not the best for that thing but it is
for the the hawk right the hawk is gonna
eat it maybe feed it to its kids and
perpetuate its own being both as an
individual and as a species and we can
say well this is better for the
ecosphere you know where you don't want
to have too many doves around eating
everything up you need some Hawks to
keep them in line and we can go on and
on and on this is this is a place where
the argument could possibly break down
but we don't have to be hyper concerned
with that at this point what is the
point that Thomas wants to make well
you don't get that kind of directedness
just by relying on say natural laws or
Instinct by themselves you need
something that is actually going to
direct them
right he says that
um nothing that lacks cognition
tends towards a goal no intendent in
Phenom unless
it is directed director
by some other thing
that is intelligent and
um you know thinking cognos kente at
intelligente and he gives the example of
the Archer the sage Torre and the arrow
you know the Arrow does not direct
itself
somebody's got to actually direct it
towards the thing now okay this is kind
of an extended metaphor is he saying
that you know every single natural thing
is being directed by something with
cognition and intelligence in as direct
way as the Archer and the arrow no I
don't think that that is implicit there
it's just a example that's being used to
illustrate it but there is a Direction
that's being given to the thing that
lacks thought or intelligence that leads
to some sort of good
reliable outcomes for it which we can
observe
so this means that there is something
with some sort of
uh thought and intelligence and now he
moves to thinking about this universally
and this might seem a little bit
underargued for you and this is I think
why it's important that we look at the
second objection in just a moment so he
goes on and he says therefore there is
some intelligence
something that is intelligizing
something that is carrying out uh uh
thinking
by which
all natural things
are ordered to their end
and then he tells us well this is what
we call God and notice that again as
with the fourth way he's no longer
saying and everybody calls this God or
everybody understands this to be God
he's saying we call this God right so
there's the possibility that maybe
others don't call that thing God maybe
they call it something else maybe they
don't actually recognize it or
understand it now I do want to point out
so this is where we might you know move
around in the article there is an
objection that's made right if a few
causes fully account for some effect you
don't need more it seems that everything
we observe in this world can be fully
accounted by other causes without
assuming a god natural effects accounted
by other natural effects are explained
by natural causes and
um
contrived or proposed or intended
effects can be explained by human
reasoning and will so we don't need to
assume a god so
um we could say that perhaps think about
breeding for example why is it that
certain animals have certain instincts I
mean now we're at the point where we can
actually start monkeying around with the
genetic code of organisms as well right
so maybe we human beings not in Thomas's
time so much but in our own time
can give a proper direction to an end
for things that are lacking cognition
you know maybe we make earthworms that
eat up Plastics or something like that I
mean we're in the realm of Science
Fiction here but we can have that as a
thought experiment and so we've got our
Laboratories and our scientists working
on it and they take the earthworms and
produce a new species of earthworms that
deals with our plastic pollution Problem
by going around and gobbling it up and I
don't know turning it into something
that they like or something that we like
okay yeah that could that could happen
um but that still doesn't account for
us and we're going to get to that in a
moment natural causes according to
Thomas
are not going to explain the
directedness to an end you've got to
have some sort of intelligent agent that
introduced those natural causes or
structures or rules or procedures or
whatever we want to call them that
produce the reliability and the
um let's call it you know best function
of those things now he says something
very interesting about
effects that are intended or contrived
however we want to translate that
so he says that natural causes act for
definite purposes under the direction of
some higher cost okay so that's gone
in the same manner
these effects of human will and
reasoning must likewise be referred back
to a higher cause than human reasoning
and will why his argument is these are
changeable and can cease to be and all
changeable things and things that cease
to be required some first cause so
that's you know the third way but we
could also say
um
how did reasoning and will even come
about in the first place in the way that
they operate not just in their mere
being the fact that we have reason and
will
but how is it that they are structured
in the way that they work so that they
actually have their own purposes and
ends which could include changing
natural things or changing ourselves
well that comes from this some
intelligence ordering all natural things
to the end or their ends and that would
be in this case once again God so Thomas
is looking at the things of the world in
which we observe some sort of regularity
some sort of you know Fitness some sort
of uh intentionality it seems or turning
out right and saying well there has to
be some sort of cause of all of this and
that cause better be the most
intelligent cause the one that others
come from so that is the fifth way
coupled together with the response
months to the second objection and what
we get here is sort of a standard Fair
teleological or design argument